hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today I just wanted to update
you all again on the upcoming
lawbreakers beta on June 28th if you
have a beta key and then the open beta
for the game on June 30th it'll go all
the way up to July 3rd which is a day it
will end this bid is only for PC and
there is a length to sign up if you want
sadly though the game is only on PC and
ps4 so no Xbox one but the dev team said
they were glad they make a version of
the Xbox if it gets enough support but
since they have a small dev team full of
about 60 people they won't be able to
make one as of right now I'm not
stopping for honor and I don't plan on
to as all of you know I just want to do
more games on this channel I'm just I'm
still going to be covering the patch
notes in the updates on for like I
always do just something just in case
nothing is going on in for honor because
sometimes always want to make a video
but there's nothing going on and I don't
have anything else to come up with this
is kind of that filler for when the days
get kind of slow the game is pretty fun
I've never actually played it it does
look nice it kind of reminds me of an
unreal tournament or a quake type view
but with a lot more modern graphics and
way more abilities and tactics with nine
different classes and two factions each
with their different look on that type
of class and the bit also includes six
maps and five game modes they kind of
range from a Dominion game modes like in
for honor to a game mode in blitz a game
mode called blitzball that kind of
similar to uplink from Call of Duty's if
any of you have ever played that also
the game is going to be costing $30 been
those season tasks because all content
is free just like titanfall 2 everything
else about the game will be explained in
the next couple days when I come up with
a beta review on it just like I
literally like I did for for honor back
in the day if you don't like the game
don't worry about it the dev stream is
coming up on Thursday so be sure to
cover that for you guys like I always do
but anyway that's all I have for me
today is a very quick video once again
to reiterate I'm not stopping for honor
and I don't plan to I'm just doing two
games at once but thank you all for
watching especially because it isn't my
type of content I normally do like the
video if you'd enjoyed dislike it if you
didn't and if you're new subscribe for
more law breakers content and then hit
that bill so you never miss an upload
and I'll see you guys in the next video
peace out